I just want to know if you get like you
know you said like Star Struck like that
character actor but like you know I'm
thinking Richard Jules at the first time
you worked with such enormous actress
because there was a lot of them in that
and you're directed by Clint Eastwood do
you get star struck by these big guys
does it kind of make you nervous in the
first few takes does it is this or are
you kind of like confident let's do my
thing
there was a there was some sort of turn
that happened with Blackbird where I I
think my experience on five and a half
months of blackbird with Taryn and
Dennis that kind of broke me of the star
struckness because I just I just like a
lot of people I have imposter syndrome
me too
um that's you know that's a normal thing
and for those listening I use that term
all the time and people are always
asking me what does that mean imposter
syndrome is essentially like akin to uh
you are in a position of some kind be it
a marriage be it a job whatever and you
feel that you don't deserve it or that
you kind of stumbled into it rather than
earned it
um and that you're gonna maybe be found
out by these people in this circumstance
so
so I I you know on I Tonya I had a day
where Margo
uh is skating and I'm supposed to be
talking to her and she kind of
bad-mouths me in this ice rink and I
what I knew I wasn't getting the face I
wanted I wasn't able to like I wasn't
eliciting enough pain and it was because
she and I had hung out at that point and
talked and like we're buddy buddy and I
was like I kind of need something from
her that will make me
feel like crap and I can really live in
it and so apparently the mirror wasn't
enough
um come on but I went up to her and I
said can you tell me I'm inadequate and
she's like what do you mean like in the
like say that in the scene and I was
like no no can you Margo tell me Paul
you're inadequate and she's like oh like
she looked disgusted and she's like I
don't want to say that and I was like I
know I need it though and she looked at
me she goes okay and she literally takes
like a beat like a thoughtful beat and
then looks up at me and goes
Paul you're inadequate
and I felt it and I was like Oh and it
did hurt and I was like good I'm glad I
did that then she went away and we did
the take and the take was really good
and she like skated up to me afterwards
I was like I'm sorry I didn't mean that
I was like no I know I just I because I
I I feel that um and then after
Blackbird you know Dennis and Taryn
treated me like a co-conspirator like a
true equal and that sort of
feeling really rubbed off on me and made
me feel like I had a place here and that
I yeah I could be a leader on and Offset
you belong yeah yeah I really did
um and and so after that I would say
going into 2022 I I I don't really get
Star Struck anymore I was a little nerd
I just worked on Matt Damon and Casey
Affleck on a Doug Lyman movie
um I have a few more days on that what's
it called it's called the instigators
but you Matt Damon you were a little bit
like not Damon well Damon Inc I think
Casey's one of our best actors working
and and I think Matt is too but in a
different way in the sense of like
you know Matt Damon will make you bust
the gut in some comedy thing and then a
minute later he's
commanding a Ridley Scott film or he's
in a Chris Nolan movie so I I was a
little nervous going into that because
I'm just like these are guys I really
respect and I want to bring it I want to
bring it right I understand I'm the
seventh man you know I'm number two or
three on the bench and this is Jordan
and Pippin or whatever but I'm like if
you put me in for three minutes you
better believe I'm gonna get you two
rebounds and I'm gonna score at least
once I'm gonna try to block somebody oh
yeah I'm gonna make that three minutes
count that's a good way to think so
that's just my thing going in now is
like I do have a lot of pressure on
myself to be great right and what I've
learned most often is like you don't
have to put yourself through some
mental rigmarole for every single role
right like some stuff you know you know
how to do and you just gotta do it and
not question it and pretend you're going
to get the peripheral Oscar or something
yeah